to begin the beer making process the
brewmaster fills a tank called a mash
tun with water then ignites a burner
when the water heats to 65 degrees
Celsius he pours in a blend of different
types of malts malts our cereal grains
such as barley or corn which have been
soaked to kickstart germination then
once sprouted dried with hot air to halt
germination stirring the malt into the
hot water activates enzymes that convert
the starches in the grain into
fermentable sugars after an hour or so
he transfers just the liquid called wert
to the boil kettle and gradually adds
different varieties of hops he brings
the work to a boil to kill off bacteria
and sterilize it next he cools the word
and transfers it to the fermentation
tank then he adds yeast over the next 10
to 14 days the yeast consumes the
fermentable sugars in the work
converting them into alcohol and
producing carbon dioxide gas which
creates bubbles this process transforms
the word into beer to prepare coffee for
the Vino brew a worker puts grounds into
a filter bag saturates the bag with cold
water then submerges the bag in water
letting the ground steep for about 16
hours then he pours the coffee into a
large jar
at the winery they harvest and press the
grapes add yeast and ferment them then
age the port wine for at least two years
in oak barrels to prepare to make vino
brew they test samples from different
barrels for acidity and sweetness to
help decide which wines to potentially
use the winemaker and the coffee maker
experiment with amounts of those wines
and different cold brew coffee made from
various types of beans the brew master
also joins in measuring out beer it's as
much art as science for each batch of
vino brew they play with the selection
of ingredients and with the proportions
tasting and smelling the samples to
evaluate aroma sweetness bitterness and
acidity what they try to create is the
harmonious blend of the three elements a
new flavor without the taste of any one
element dominating the others
[Music]
once they pin down the winning formula
they replicate it on a large scale for
production